are you for you
because i always tell people when people
ask me like about you or you come up in
conversation i feel a need to
tell people and remind people like you
kind of invented this [ __ ] like you were
playing around with your friends filming
[ __ ] editing your videos and
distributing them before youtube before
any of this [ __ ] so now for you
looking at youtube
like i don't know do you look at it like
i invented this [ __ ] kind of or like how
does it how does youtube strike you i
just
i knew that you know if if you look at
cky2k or cky1 it's something that you
could always watch because dude
skate videos just become so outdated i
remember watching plan b questionable
video over and over and over again
because it was just
such uncomparable to any other video it
was the best danny way was the best uh
it was just uncomparable and then
now it's just
they're getting better and better and
better and better and like if you even
watch questionable now it's just tricks
that kids could do for [ __ ] breakfast
right you know but i mixed in funny
ridiculous stunts in between pro skate
tricks so it never gets old you know
like
you're always gonna
laugh and watch great skating you know
um which which was completely
brand new to
the whole skating sport and when i
played it to people that weren't
skateboarders and they were laughing
hysterical telling everybody everything
was through word of mouth it sold a
million copies you know like um
that's why like you know
so i mean tremaine always says big
brother story jackets well how come i
sold over a million
copies and big brother only sold like 80
000 or something like that like he never
gives me [ __ ] credit is that what cky
did out of the bootleg tapes yeah we
never had one ad and i sold over a
million of every single one of them
millions and millions of copies yeah i
mean everybody had cky 2k
ui was definitely
a huge deal you know yeah um
and
i agree with you there except for
i think we got to acknowledge that it
was knoxville and tremaine who reached
out to spike and got it going and then
they reached out to you saying hey do
you want to come on board with this
thing so how come how come spike jones
has so much say in jackets when he came
in a decade later
because he had the
the
clout
the name the you know the the power to
make this
[ __ ] thing start nobody else would
have uh
if spike's name wasn't attached to
jackass in the beginning people would
have looked at it and said you can't put
this [ __ ] [ __ ] on tv no but wait a
minute but when jackass the first season
on mtv he he wasn't a part of it wasn't
yeah he was
absolutely he was for sure and he also
helped like shape the look of the show a
little bit yeah like uh i did not know
that i i just thought ten years later he
popped up
and then that was that the only the only
way they even got a meeting was because
spike was attached to it and i guess he
was just so m.i.a all the time i just
didn't know that he was even a part of
it spike was the one who opened the door
and i genuinely believed that without
spike people would have looked at the
footage that they were trying to sell
and said you cannot put this [ __ ]
reckless violent [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] on
tv like spike has made phenomenal movies
because spike's name was attached to it
it somehow
made what we do permissible for
broadcast television you know yeah i
know well i heard i heard the first
pitch to like hbo or something was like
we're not [ __ ] ever playing this you
crazy and then i guess mtv was like all
right we'll give it a shot and then like
a light switch and spike was in both of
those meetings it was a massive massive
hit oh yeah oh yeah
so technically they did it
the funniest [ __ ] thing ever they
never made it though there's some things
that don't make it to jackie ass and one
of them was dave england was at the
venice beach
no no he was john pictures his old ass
i was like i'll take my picture drawn by
you for five dollars you sit there like
this only to reveal
her naked ass saggy tip with a minion
ass [ __ ] and it just says [ __ ] she's
like you need church
they're like we will never ever ever
i think this is the best [ __ ] skit
ever but i agree this should never be
aired on television right
yeah
big an ass [ __ ] saggy just
i didn't know that that didn't air i
thought like i thought it did but either
way i remember and i remember it just
about as fondly as you do it's called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on amazon and type in stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude